all right everyone we got will here with
us right now we're currently looking at
bitcoin sitting around 48 000 or so uh
let's start with the realized price
distribution or you are pd what are you
seeing there
yeah so this is just basically uh on
chain volume profile um you're basically
looking at like at which different price
levels a certain amount of bitcoin was
moved um and so like we have this
massive zone of volume that was formed
while we
went sideways for three months between
30 40k
and that's below us and then as well we
have a fair amount of distribution kind
of like the mid 40k is between call it
like 44 to 47k that we're kind of uh we
well we just now broke through that so
yeah we have a good amount of uh support
under us in that sense
all right and then the miners when china
banned a bunch of the miners uh
obviously hash rate dropped
significantly but the miners that stayed
on what happened with them they got
super profitable
yeah so when we had this big drop in
hash rate we had a record difficulty
adjustment that followed and so what it
meant is that
the miners that were still left on the
network became way more profitable
especially in north america
and so this is shown in this chart what
you see is um the the green line is is
uh hash per i'm sorry revenue per hash
um and then the purple line is just the
hash rate and so what you see is this
correlation between um as as hash went
down and we had the difficulty
adjustment then the miners like we just
said still on the network were more
profitable but as hash has started to
slowly come back on the network over the
last few weeks uh that profitability is
kind of fizzling out if you will but it
you know it's still way higher than it
was compared to a few months ago
but yeah hash is starting to come back
online slowly so far from
you know where it was before the chinese
uh you know minor migration but you know
just looking positive and so when we
look at their actual net position change
this has been positive they've been
accumulating bitcoin not selling it for
a while now has that continued
yeah for sure um you know just it makes
sense because they're more profitable
right so they don't have to sell as many
bitcoins to cover their operational
costs
and so this is looking at the 30-day
change between minor balances 30 days
ago on the 20th of july versus august
20th and so what you see is that
you know it's been staying in the green
and over the last you know called week
or so it's actually moved up so yes
seeing strong accumulation from miners
which you know as we just looked at the
profitability uh you know completely
makes sense yep so pretty much since the
beginning of july once they went from
selling a bunch of bitcoin uh to now
holding it accumulating it uh that's
actually accelerated as well which we're
seeing here in the chart another metric
that you uh included this week which uh
i don't think i actually understand is
market cap to thermo cap ratio explain
to us what is this and then what is this
chart showing us
yeah sure this was created by uh nick
carter it's just looking at the the
market cap of bitcoin in comparison to
like the total revenue that miners have
ever brought in because that makes sense
and so like what you basically get is
these over in underheated zones and
obviously like the peak of the bowl in
the bottom of the bear in terms of like
the speculative premium that's bit up on
the marginal
from the marginal buyer in comparison to
um the the
the revenue that miners are bringing in
yeah so super bullish to see it kind of
uh what appeared to be it was going down
and that trend reversed uh pretty
significantly and we're kind of headed
back up now
yeah and then also you never really
reach like a real overheated zone at
least just you know compared to
historical peaks uh and and yeah so like
over the last couple weeks this started
to move back up as well yep one of my
favorite stats right now is the realized
capped uh is at this all-time high
explain what realized cap is and then uh
what you think uh kind of the
ramifications of it hitting an all-time
high are
yeah realize cap was also created by uh
nick carter uh this is basically looking
at if anybody doesn't know nick carter
is like crazy smart um realize cap is
basically the the average weighted price
of bitcoin so it's the capitalization
based off of when coins were last moved
so like
you know if if you bought a hundred
thousand dollars a bitcoin at a dollar
well then you're adding a hundred
thousand dollars to realize cap if those
coins have still not moved since when
you bought them at a dollar then still
only added 100 thousand dollars to
realize cap while you know in market cap
terms you're you're just um
you know that's like four point whatever
now we're at 48k so it's 4.8 billion
dollars that's uh the chunk of market
capitalization that those coins are
contributing to so it's basically like a
v walk which is a volume weighted
average price of bitcoin um and so like
seeing that seeing that reaching new
highs and showing two things um
well not too a few things so like a
coins are
being um they're no longer being sold at
a loss because like if you
like i said it's based off of when their
last move so if they're last moved at
60k and then they were moved at 30k well
you have 30 thousand dollars removed
from the realized cap so seeing seeing
it go up is showing that coins are
moving from below and not above
and so also it's showing that there's
new capital inflows um that that's
coming in and they're buying at these
higher prices so it's a really good sign
basically showing like the markets
absorbing um the profits that are being
taken from below
i saw dylan leclair say bitcoin all-time
high september
when do you think we hit an all-time
high do you have a uh an estimation
ah
do i say something for engagement or do
i try to be objective here
you pick is
let me see
i'm gonna say this
i'll say by the end of the year
i think 75k is conservative whether we
get new all-time highs next month
i i think it's kind of up in in the air
to an extent
um it could depend on like some macro
factors because
you know macro doesn't look
really great right now so
if we don't get like any of those
existential threats then i'll say yeah
we get all-time highest next month okay
second question
where we sit today if you had to pick
what's the highest you could see it
going not saying it's going there but
what's the absolute highest you can see
bitcoin going this year
yeah so i have a price model basically
looking at like the historical tops it's
marked the historical time it wasn't
built by nations but by william
it's time marked historical tops within
like five percent
and so right now that model's sitting
right around 176k
um
right now though so there's a couple
different if i get into the math of it
i'm probably going to pour people to
sleep but
i'm looking for us to cross this this
threshold of about 57 58k it's sloping
upwards but once we cross that um i'll
have full bull market confirmation if
you will even though i
i'm
pretty you know strongly believe that we
are in a bull market now
but once we get over that then i'll have
that full confirmation which also by the
time we get there we'll probably be
earning all-time highs anyway but once
we get above that i'd probably be
targeting around uh
9294k which is the next
kind of
threshold in that model so
right now looking to see if we get above
that once we get above that we'll be
targeting around mid 90ks and then if we
can get above that then you know we'll
see where that top model is kind of
sloping at i suspect you know by then
it'll probably be up near 200k because
it's it's flipping upwards uh but yeah
for now it's around 176k
so 176 to 200 000 not saying it's going
there but uh it's possible
yeah
you know perhaps that'd be like the
absolute cycle top hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it